China “appears to be… construct[ing] the
ultimate tool of social control” … a “comprehensive
‘credit score’ system” … that will
“make your head spin.”
…That’s what the American Civil Liberties
Union (ACLU) wrote on October 5th, 2015.
This newly emerging, soon to be all-encompassing
surveillance network, it said, would give
everyone in China a score between 350 and
nine hundred and fifty.
But unlike, say, American credit scores, these
would punish everything from jaywalking to
government criticism.
Even more disturbingly, you could be responsible
for the actions of friends and family.
The rest of this article mainly focused on
the United States.
The ACLU, after all, is an American non-profit.
It lobbies for things like free speech, privacy,
and criminal justice reform.
This was not new reporting.
The author was open about his sources — other
articles he had read online.
Neither did he claim any expertise on China.
In fact, just three days later, he updated
the article, softening the tone and emphasizing
that he only meant to caution against “potential
abuses” in America.
But it didn’t matter.
What mattered was that a high-profile, well-respected
institution had stamped its seal of approval
and other organizations took notice.
Two days after the original ACLU article went
live and a day before it issued the update,
Computerworld re-published it, calling the
Chinese system “Orwellian”.
Popular Science wrote that although, quote,
“the system isn’t explicitly dystopian
yet…
it has all the pieces to be dystopian at a
moment’s notice.”
And Reason claimed these scores would soon
“define Chinese citizens' lives”.
In less than a week, the Social Credit System
had not only entered the English-media landscape,
but also, seemingly, amassed a body of evidence.
Multiple sources endorsing the same alarming
conclusion.
Never mind that they all referenced the same
ACLU report written by a non-expert, largely
about the United States, itself based on earlier
speculation.
News travels fast.
And headlines even faster.
There was no need for some grand conspiracy
to smear China or bad faith on the part of
any individual author.
The simple market pressures of 21st-century
journalism were enough to make a story appear
out of thin air.
America’s (often quite justified) suspicion
of the Chinese government and technology in
general, were just icing on the cake.
Since then, the social credit system has truly
taken on a life of its own, with coverage
by the Financial Times, Economist, Fortune,
and countless others.
This now eight year-old game of telephone
culminated in an appearance at the White House,
with Vice President Mike Pence describing
it as “an Orwellian system premised on controlling
virtually every facet of human life.”
And yet, ask a friend, colleague, or classmate
who’s spent time in China about their experience
and you’ll likely be met with confusion.
This is not a case of censorship.
The Chinese government does engage in extensive
censorship, but for the social credit system
to work as described, the public must be,
at a minimum, aware of its existence.
Neither is this the result of propaganda.
The government does engage in propaganda,
but in this case, the response is not anger,
frustration, or disagreement — just confusion.
Because, for all its well-documented, genuine
atrocities, the “Orwellian” credit score
system imagined by many in the media simply
doesn’t exist.
The truth, however, is far more revealing.
Sponsored by Skillshare.
Get a one-month free trial and start learning
everything from programming to graphic design.
In June 2014, the State Council of China published
this “Planning Outline for the Establishment
of a Social Credit System”
Now, the first thing you should know about
this document is that it’s incredibly boring
and almost artfully vague.
Full of dense phrases like “Promote the
improvement of legal person governance”,
you almost have to admire how little it manages
to say in 16,000 Chinese characters.
The second thing to note is the broader context
in which it was released.
One month earlier, in May of 2014, the same
government announced what it described as
a “war on terror” against violent extremism
in Xinjiang.
This would later evolve into a full-blown
attack on Uyghurs and other ethnic minorities
including mass incarceration, surveillance,
and violence that continues, in modified form,
to this day.
In other words, this was a time when much
of the world was becoming — understandably
— increasingly skeptical of the Chinese
government, and here was this new, suspiciously
ambiguous notion of “social credit”.
The motive for some kind of inescapable system
of surveillance and control seemed undeniable.
In fact, what made the myth so potent was
that it did contain an element of truth.
In the years since, China has constructed
a similarly oppressive, albeit less high-tech,
police state in Xinjiang, involving DNA collection,
phone searches, and security checkpoints.
Besides, what else could the term “social
credit” refer to?
And if it truly had nothing to hide, why was
the plan written in such cryptic language?
But what few casual observers understood is
that cryptic, inscrutable Leninist-steeped
jargon is kind of the Chinese Communist Party’s
whole thing.
And there’s a very specific reason…
The benefits of autocracy for an autocrat
are so obvious — complete, unchecked authority
— that it’s easy to forget the trade-off.
With complete authority comes complete responsibility.
There’s no one to blame.
Consider how often Democrats and Republicans
use each other as scapegoats.
Dictators don’t have that luxury.
So, to insulate themselves from criticism,
they often delegate a lot more power than
you might expect.
Now, make no mistake, Beijing always gets
the final word, but think of it as an architect.
It produces the national blueprint, first
in the form of a policy document, and later,
a policy outline, but whose actual implementation
it outsources to lower levels of government
— its engineers.
When the actual building looks nothing like
the concept art, the central government can
keep its hands clean by pointing to its beautifully
vague, boringly-unobjectionable sketches.
At the same time, it also, of course, has
things it wants to accomplish — things that
need to be communicated to the ‘engineers’.
Thus, while these policy documents, as we
saw, are indeed horribly tedious, they’re
not entirely devoid of content.
You just have to understand Party-speak.
So, what did it mean by “social credit”?
According to Jeremy Daum, Senior Fellow at
Yale Law School’s Paul Tsai China Center
and someone fluent in Party-speak, it was
never a single policy.
It wasn’t even a very well-outlined goal.
Instead, it was always, quote, “shorthand
for a broad range of efforts”.
The first of which was financial.
In short, the millions born before the One-Child
Policy became law in 1980 were in their prime
working-age years during the Chinese boom
of the 80s, 90s, and early 2000s.
That large mass of workers kept labor costs
down, attracting foreign companies, who, in
turn, invested that profit back into the country.
But, as all those workers began to retire,
Chinese labor became a lot more expensive,
leading to lower profits, and therefore, less
investment.
That investment, however, could be replaced
with consumption.
In summary: if China was to keep growing,
it needed to start spending.
Yet, at the time, just one-fifth of the population
had a credit report.
Without banks or credit cards, they couldn’t
take out loans.
And without loans, they couldn’t spend as
much money.
Meanwhile, much of this large, unbanked population
used Chinese apps like WeChat and AliPay on
a daily basis.
So, the thinking was, what if all that data
could be used to create alternative credit
scores?
Eight private companies were selected to do
just that as part of a pilot project.
The most famous was “Sesame Credit”, an
optional service that gave users a three-digit
score.
The second and larger focus of “social credit”
was centered around trust.
Ironically, while outsiders view China as
a tightly-controlled, closely-monitored police
state, many in China saw their country as
the “Wild West” — untamed, unregulated,
and lacking in consequences.
In 2008, for instance, a company was caught
using toxic chemicals in its milk and baby
formula, making thousands of children sick.
Scandals like these left deep nationwide scars.
Some parents are — understandably — still
suspicious of Chinese milk today.
At the same time, corruption — once tolerated
as a necessary ingredient to rapid economic
growth — was beginning to reach a boiling
point.
Not only was the Party losing control of its
own members, but the public was starting to
take notice.
Stories of county bureaucrats driving Lamborghinis,
despite their measly official salaries, were
attracting a bit too much attention.
And, in the eyes of the Party, all these things
were connected.
The milk, the corruption…
it all represented a crisis of moral failure.
One consequence of which was a general lack
of trust throughout Chinese society.
The solution was to build what it called,
in its typically ambiguous way, a “reputation
society”.
Remember, this was the architect telling the
engineer: “here’s a vaguely-defined problem,
now go try and solve it.”
The results were as random and chaotic as
you’d expect.
What, as a local bureaucrat, are you supposed
to do with those instructions?
No one knows, and that’s the point.
A few dozen cities across China rushed to
implement their own “social credit” reputation
systems, each with their own set of rules
and rewards.
One city announced it would subtract 3 points
for every five cigarettes smoked and add 5
for every 15,000 steps walked.
No explanation was offered for how these numbers
were determined, much less how this could
possibly be enforced, but it didn’t matter.
The public backlash was so strong that the
proposal was abandoned.
Bizarrely, another city said it would penalize
drunk driving and reward volunteer work, but
then decided to make the system optional.
A third city gave every citizen a grade from
A to D, until someone compared it to the Japanese
Occupation of China and it quietly disappeared.
It was all very weird and impractical.
Needless to say, the Central government was…
thoroughly unimpressed.
Evidently, the construction didn’t match
the blueprint.
Alternatively, perhaps Beijing miscalculated
the public’s reaction and saw its opportunity
to swoop in and ‘protect’ the country
from those terrible, no-good engineers.
The People’s Bank of China refused to renew
the licenses of all eight companies participating
in the financial pilot project.
Beijing also called out several local governments
for being overzealous, instructing them to
only punish what was already illegal.
The third and final component of social credit
are blacklists.
Previously, each government ministry maintained
separate records, meaning someone could violate
the rules of, say, the tax authorities, without
the food inspector knowing.
Now they’re supposed to share that data,
not only internally but also with the public,
so, for example, you could search the name
of a company and decide if it’s reputable.
Generally trustworthy entities are placed
on so-called “red-lists” and repeat offenders
on blacklists.
Most of these are companies, though their
owners and managers can be implicated too.
As a ballpark, somewhere between about 1 and
2% of companies and 0.15 to .3 percent of
people are blacklisted each year.
In the most extreme case, offenders are banned
from taking flights or trains, or sending
their children to private schools.
But these restrictions only apply to one type
of offense, those who refuse to pay damages
found by a judge, despite having the requisite
funds.
Once they’ve fulfilled their court orders,
they’re removed from the blacklist.
By 2018, over 12 million of these “judgment
defaulters” had been affected.
Some cities even broadcast their names in
movie theaters.
Okay, let’s review…
One part of “social credit” was “financial”,
one about cities incentivizing “good behavior”,
and the third an attempt to share government
data.
The first involved eight companies, the second,
dozens of different cities, and the third,
several independent ministries.
One was private, the other two, public.
Some were optional, others not.
Together, they have very little in common
besides the label “social credit”.
If you’re not at least slightly confused
by now, you should probably be concerned.
Remember, this was not designed for global
comprehension.
Actually, it wasn’t really designed for
local comprehension.
It was designed to leave the door open for
experimentation and to retain some plausible
deniability for the central government.
So, it should be no surprise that virtually
every detail was lost on the media.
Instead of three separate projects, many journalists
lumped them all together as one.
The inputs of privately-owned Sesame Credit
— your shopping behavior, for instance — were
paired with the state-sponsored punishments
of the entirely separate blacklists — travel
restrictions, for example.
Thus, the story became “if you buy the wrong
things, the CCP will ban you from travel”.
“Social credit” was an easy device through
which to conceive of and critique Chinese
authoritarianism.
The irony being that the reason this 1984-style
surveillance was so believable in the first
place is also the reason the Party doesn’t
need it.
Chinese surveillance isn’t some new development.
The battle for anonymity was lost well before
the birth of social credit.
All accounts on all Chinese websites require
real-name registration.
So does every SIM card, and internet cafe.
If and when laws — including social credit
— are weaponized, it’s because of the
underlying system — the nearly unchecked
discretion afforded to individual police officers
and bureaucrats.
Now, it would be clean and simple to end the
video here by concluding that journalists
are just ‘lazy’ and ran with a false narrative.
But that too would be lazy.
This is not just a case of journalists seeing
what they wanted to see.
Because China also feeds into these pre-existing
anxieties.
To see how, humor me with one final tangent.
In democracies, ‘politics’ seem to get
in the way of simple solutions to healthcare,
education, and infrastructure.
When Congress can’t seem to get anything
done, it’s easy to start thinking of party
politics as a bug, not a feature.
“If only I were General Secretary for a
day, everything would be so much better”
If democracy is messy, inefficient, and complicated,
autocracy must be clean, efficient, and simple.
But not necessarily.
If you’re a student, think about the last
time you tried to herd the sheep that were
the members of your group project.
If you work in an office, recall how difficult
it is to get sales and finance to collaborate.
Now multiply that complexity by 100 million
people — the size of the Communist Party.
Though they may march under the same banner,
people are people.
100 million members means 100 million feuds,
allegiances, and career ambitions.
By delegating power in order to share responsibility,
China opens the door to a certain version
of messy politics.
Both the local governments and private companies
responsible for implementing Beijing’s vision
of “social credit” had their own incentives,
one of which was to overstate their capabilities.
If you think Silicon Valley is the capital
of empty buzzwords, try talking to executives
at Alibaba or Party officials from up-and-coming
cities like Suzhou.
Desperate to impress their bosses in Beijing,
they throw around terms like “big data”,
“blockchain”, and “smart cities” like
it’s no one’s business.
Take Sesame Credit, for instance.
To curry favor with the authorities, the company
painted a beautiful picture full of super
advanced algorithms.
To entice users, it advertised powerful benefits
like travel visas to Europe.
The English-language media, already believing
Sesame Credit to be the official manifestation
of “social credit”, effectively bought
into this marketing, which it then resold
to a global audience by emphasizing how this
“super advanced” technology could be weaponized.
In reality, Sesame Credit was a — frankly
amateur — version of the Target RedCard
— it calculated how often, not what you
purchased, whether you’d completed your
profile, not what it said, and how many accounts
you’d added on the app as “friends”,
not who they were.
In exchange for sharing this basic data with
the company, you could do things like rent
a bike without leaving a deposit.
A high score couldn’t grant you a visa to
Europe — only Europe can do that.
All it could do is help prove your finances,
replacing one of several documents required
to apply.
Likewise, local governments love nebulous
terms like “social credit” because unlike,
say, GDP growth, it’s very hard to measure.
This lack of oversight makes it all too easy
to exaggerate claims about “algorithms”
— which often meant simple addition and
subtraction — and “big data” — which
was often recorded on spreadsheets, or in
one city, I kid you not, clipboards.
This, for instance, is the average number
of data points per citizen in each of these
five pilot cities.
The social credit dystopia imagined by many,
on the other hand, would require close coordination
between hundreds of different ministries — all
of which are competing for promotions, budget
allocations, and regulatory authority.
This is not at all to say China is incapable
of doing big and scary things.
The point is that we should approach its claims
about “big data” and “machine learning”
with the same degree of skepticism as we would
any Silicon Valley startup.
Currently, one side is primed to see China
as ten-feet tall and the other is incentivized
to exaggerate its height — what could go
wrong?
Conversely, what you can’t go wrong with
are these classes on productivity and learning
new things with spaced repetition that can
help you advance or kick start a new career.
We all have dreams, goals, and creative projects
in mind.
But, if you’re like me, you need that little
push to get things going.
Maybe you’ve always wanted to learn graphic
design but don’t know where to start.
This class walks you through everything you
need to know about Photoshop, right from the
very basics.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with not only thousands of courses on everything
from graphic design to programming but also
a superior learning environment.
By sharing your work with others, getting
feedback, and asking questions, you can engage
with each lesson and feel rewarded.
Because you get access to every lesson with
a single subscription, you’re motivated
to learn more to make the most of your membership.
The first 1,000 people to join by clicking
the link on screen now get a one-month free
trial.
That’s one full month you can take unlimited
classes with no restrictions.
Thanks again to Skillshare for sponsoring
this video.